hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 26 hört zu und spricht nach
gib mir bitte einen kugelschreiber gib
mir bitte einen kugelschreiber schaltete
das licht aus
schaltet
das licht ausschaltet jetzt den
fernseher ausschaltet jetzt den
fernseher aus schaltete das licht an
schaltete das licht an sei leise sei
leise
seit leise seit leise
mach bitte das fenster auf mach bitte
das fenster auf mach bitte die tür zu
machte die tür zu ist mehr gemüse isst
mehr gemüse hör auf zu rauchen
hör auf zu rauchen
sprich bitte langsam sprich bitte
langsam sprechen sie bitte hochdeutsch
sprechen sie bitte hochdeutsch rufen
zurück ruf mich bitte zurück gut frau
müller ich habe jetzt die resultate des
blutes
ich hoffe es ist alles gut herr dr
ja frau müller es ist nicht schlimm
ihr blutdruck ist ein wenig erhöht
ich gebe ihnen
für hier ein medikament
nehmen sie das medikament zweimal pro
tag am morgen und am abend nehmen sie
das medikament zweimal pro tag am morgen
und am abend
das werde ich machen herr doktor
außerdem sollten sie sich mehr bewegen
gehen sie jeden tag 30 minuten spazieren
einverstanden herr doktor
da ist noch etwas sie sind ja im moment
leicht erkältet trinken sie deshalb viel
tee trinken sie deshalb viel tee das
mache ich schon herr doktor aber mein
husten geht trotzdem nicht weg
gegen den husten gebe ich ihnen hier
einen hustensaft nehmen sie jeden abend
einen großen löffel davon gut
gegen den husten gebe ich ihnen hier
einen hustensaft nehmen sie jeden abend
einen großen löffel davon gut noch etwas
ich habe ihnen ja empfohlen spazieren zu
gehen
ziehen sie sich dabei warm an es ist ja
schon ziemlich kalt draußen tragen sie
auf jeden fall einen schal und eine
warme jacke
ziehen sie sich dabei warm an
es ist ja schon ziemlich kalt draußen
tragen sich auf jeden fall einen schal
und eine warme jacke
das werde ich machen herr dr
sehr gut dann wünsche ich ihnen gute
besserung frommel werden sie schnell
gesund
sehr gut dann wünsche ich ihnen gute
besserung frommel werden sie schnell
gesund
das will ich hoffen herr doktor vielen
dank
auf wiedersehen
auf wiedersehen frau müller
hört jetzt gut zu hört jetzt gut zu
meiner kinder
wartet kinder geht sofort zurück in eure
plätze geht doch zurück in eure plätze
setzt euch auf eure stühle und zeit
ruhig setzt euch auf eure stühle und
zeit ruhig
mg mg
dich dich
richtig richtig
das licht das licht die pflicht die
pflicht
michael michael zeichnen zeichnen gleich
gleich reich reich rechnen rechnen
sprechen sprechen
der mechaniker der mechaniker
die nächte die fächer die fächer die
dächer die dächer tüchtig tüchtig die
küche die küche die bücher die bücher
möchten möchten die töchter die töchter
die köchin die köchin wäsche
wöchentlich das buch das buch
suchen suchen buchen buchen machen
machen
der nachmittag der nachmittag die
sprache die sprache
lachen
lacht
der bauch der bauch
der schlauch der schlauch
rauchen rauchen
kochen kochen